[Inaudible].
I ran a Saurus Rex King of the title.
Lizards.
Meters, tall, 12 meters long,
and it weighs upward of seven tons.
You can hide from it. You might even be able to outrun it.
But do you.
Really want to do this every day?
What would it be like to live with T-Rex would
we keep them in zoos? Would we eat them in restaurants?
Would we wear them on our backs or would we live in
constant fear of being chomped.
Or tramp is.
Use? What would happen if T-Rex were still alive?
Roughly 66 million years ago,
a massive asteroid thought to be about 15 kilometers wide,
hit the earth with an impact equal to several million nuclear
bombs detonating at once.
This triggered the sudden mass extinction of approximately
75% of all plant and animal species on the planet
among them was the most powerful terrestrial predator to have ever lived.
The Tyrannosaurus Rex as one of the most popular
prehistoric animals.
Being able to see a T-Rex in the flesh is a pretty common fantasy,
but what if we got what we wished war and T-Rex
were still alive today,
would humanity be able to survive alongside them
were T-Rex as vicious and as ruthless as they appear to be in
movies and TV,
or would these massive dinosaurs be more worried about us
than we'd be of them? If T-Rex were alive today,
chances are they'd be an endangered species. They're terrifying.
Reputation would be no match for the habitat loss pollution and
food shortages caused by humans because of this T-Rex
populations would be a lot smaller and it's even possible
that they would have evolved to be a smaller size.
We'd probably have to keep them in sanctuaries similar to a wildlife
Safari since letting them roam freely would be bad for both T-Rex
and humans in the wild.
A T-Rex would have to look out for hunters,
poachers who want the thrill and the bragging rights of taking down a
seven ton beast.
But even if you were smart enough to keep your distance a hungry,
T-Rex looking for food might find itself stumbling onto a farm or
breaking into a city zoo.
And if you can't imagine a rampaging two wrecks storming around your
city,
just imagine an upright bus with two legs and sharp teeth
that have a maximum bite force of about 5,800 kilograms,
but it's not like T-Rex would always be out hunting humans.
Scientific evidence suggests that T-Rex,
might've been more like scavengers than predators.
Unlike most predators that tend to have super sharp vision,
a T-Rex his eyes were small and weak.
This dinosaur also had unusually small arms compared to the rest of their body,
which wouldn't have been very effective for fighting prey.
However,
T-Rex did have unusually large olfactory lobes as part of their
brains,
which scientists think would have been helpful for smelling rotting carcasses
from far away.
But that same powerful sense of smell might also draw T-Rex
to country ranches or urban meat factories,
which would almost certainly end in disaster.
A T-Rex could eat up to 230 kilograms of meat in just
one bite. So your farm animals wouldn't last very long.
And if you wanted to defend them or simply prevent your house from being
crushed, you wouldn't be able to take on a T-Rex without a gun.
And if he didn't have one,
you'd have to run for your life directs.
Weren't super fast runners with some scientists believing their top speed
was around 16 kilometers an hour.
So if you ran and hid in a dense forest where it would be hard for them to
maneuver, you might be safe.
You could also try to trip the T-Rex.
That's chasing you since they're top heavy dinosaurs that had a hard time
getting up. If they fell, of course, we wouldn't have to worry about anything,
your livestock and outsmarting T-Rex.
If we kept them safely confined to wildlife preserves,
we could create large habitats for them and grow food to feed them
so that appetites wouldn't get them or us into trouble.
The sanctuaries probably wouldn't look like anything from Jurassic park since
well, we've seen how well that works,
but maybe with enough space food and under proper management,
humans could coexist with T-Rex,
but the T-Rex is just one type of dinosaur.
Could we live with others too?
What do you think the world would be like if none of the dinosaurs ever went
extinct?
Well, that's a story for another. What if.
[Inaudible].